i actually pay attention
to every breath and my spiritual
practice
is that i awaken and the first thought
is thank you
look how much more training i have done
by simply starting at four
most people don't start their day with
intention and that makes the difference
between the people who achieve success
and the ones who don't
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
habits of some of the world's richest
people
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one have a belief
practice with oprah winfrey what is my
belief practice today
today
i feel the fierce
love of all that is god
so deeply
so strongly and so purely in my heart
that it lifts
and carries me and
sometimes i actually feel weightless
in the love that is god because
i feel it in all things
i actually awakened to birds twittering
in the morning now
the original tweets and
because i'm not so focused
on because i've reached a point in my
life
where i actually pay attention
to every breath and my spiritual
practice
is that i awaken and the first thought
is thank you and
the next thought is i'm still here
in this body and
my heart's desire is to want to live and
be in this body
fully present to everything
to all beings to all things
to not miss this experience of being
here
now on the planet we call earth
habit number two write down your goals
with grant cardone
write my goals down first thing of the
day i've been doing this for 30 years
now
writing down impossible goals to achieve
things that like oh my god what would
cause me to get up today
early what would cause me to want to
make that extra phone call
what would it take what would i what
would need to propel me or
inspire me so much that i'm like i'm
willing to do all this hard stuff that
maybe i haven't been doing
and could be possibly keeping me from
getting
the life i deserve in this case the life
you deserve
i still do this today wake up in the
morning write my goals down first thing
i do is write my goals down
these are big goals unachievable goals
second thing i do is write down my quote
of the day what am i living by today
not somebody else's quote while it could
be but it's really my quote
what is the quote what am i authoring in
my life
uh who do i want to be here
she's going to have to write her own
goals down she's going to have to come
up with her own quotes
she's going to have to decide for
herself what she wants to do how she
wants to live
same thing for all of us it's a
beautiful thing about this planet we get
to decide
and do whatever we want to do or
as little
as we want to do the problem with the
little part is
if you're capable of doing more than
you're doing and you're not
probably not going to feel good about
yourself i know i did
hated myself hated myself
when i knew i could achieve more and i
wasn't
i think this is why people watch sports
see the great pass great catch great
block great tackle
great breakout tackle
a great dunk whatever the shot is
right it's like wow man that person did
something that
that is full potential and we're shocked
by it
but in reality
in reality it's probably because we know
we all have that in us
i'll bet you got more in you than you're
using right now
so try this try this simple wake up
early just try for a couple three days
three or four five days see what it
feels like
try for one day that's all you got in
you
and then two write your goals down
unachievable goals you want to be a
millionaire billionaire trillionaire
good write it down want a helicopter you
want a plane
five or ten goals that you want to
achieve or maybe more and then tomorrow
when you wake up tomorrow
do it again see which ones pop up
tomorrow now this is what i do a little
trick
i do in the morning and i do before i go
to sleep at night first thing i do when
i wake up
it's more important than your goals
first thing i do when i wake up
last thing i do before i go to sleep at
night and i'll throw one little trick in
that's how powerful it is anytime i'm
disappointed anytime i'm discouraged
anytime i'm down anytime i lose i write
my goals down again
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here habit
number three meditate with ray dalio
how long have you been meditating for
actually 42 years
and what got you started the beatles
when the beatles started meditating and
they drew attention to it and it was a
curiosity and i thought i would try it
and then it's changed my life it's
the big the biggest uh influence and
whatever success i've had in life
so can you remember what it was like in
the first few weeks or the first few
months
yeah i remember wrestling around with it
i remember that
uh you know you go into the mantra i
went into the mantra
then the thoughts would come back and it
would
be that back and forth and then as it
got
better and better and i got deeper into
it the thoughts would become
more valuable more tantalizing and it
was almost
um you know more of a temptation to
think about those particular thoughts
because i didn't want to lose those
ideas
and then i knew that i had to push those
away and it was
almost difficult and then after a while
i remember then disappearing into it
and that was something the first
benefits were
that ability that have the quietness the
tranquility
um the ability to get energy from it
rather than sleep it would provide me
more energy than sleeping
those kinds of benefits but then it went
on
to develop an ongoing equanimity
that that centeredness that ability to
go above myself and my circumstances and
to look down at them
from a higher level with a clarity and
an objectivity
and then it started to bring out my
subconscious
and my creativity
subsequently i've studied uh
neuroscience i've been very interested
in that
and um and i've learned that there's a
part of our brain
in the neocortex which is where
imagination exists
which is where creativity exists and it
opened me to that
i experienced it i didn't understand
what was happening at the time but it
provided those things as time went on
habit number four start early with kobe
bryant
if your job is to try to be the best
basketball player you can be
all right to do that you have to
practice you have to train right
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can
so if you get up at 10 in the morning
train at 11
right 12 say 12. train at 12 train for
two hours 12 to two
um you have to let your body recover so
you eat recover whatever you get back
out
you train start training again at six
train from six to eight
right and now you go home you shower you
eat dinner you go to bed you wake up you
do it again right those are two sessions
right now imagine you wake up at three
you train at four go four to six
come home breakfast relax
now you're back at it again nine to
eleven
right you relax and now all of a sudden
you're back at it again two to four
and now you're back at it again you know
seven to nine
look how much more training i have done
by simply starting at four
right so now you do that and as the
years go on
the separation that you have with your
competitors and your peers just grows
larger and larger and larger and larger
and larger
and by year five or six doesn't matter
what kind of work they do in the summer
they're never going to catch up
because you're five years behind right
so it makes sense to get up and start
your day early because you can get more
working
habit number five learn and grow with
robin sharma
when i coach the superstars i notice
they all have a trade in common
they have massive levels of what i call
curiosity
iq they understand that the person who
learns the most
produces at best okay so greatness
belongs to the learners and
fortune favors the curious so from 5
40 to 6 o'clock the final pocket for 20
20 20 formula it's when you
read an autobiography or you read a book
on productivity
or you look at your game charts on
your targets or you listen to a podcast
or you watch a video course but you give
yourself that
learning because as you know more you
can do better
in many ways the people who create
empires the people who
change history are people who are
incredible
students you know you never want to lose
a white belt mentality
because nothing fails like success i see
it with so many companies i work with
members of the fortune 100 i see it with
professional athletes
you know they have a championship season
and they start resting on their laurels
and they
you know stop learning they stop
mentoring they stop pushing themselves
to the limit but one thing the a
players and virtuosos all have in common
they understand that
last year's championship season it
is this year's starting point you know
there there was a type of slave in rome
called the auriga
and the auriga had one mission to stand
behind the dukes
which is the military commander and
whisper into his ear
momento homo memento homo
momento homo what does that mean well
it's latin for
remember you're only a man
and so let us not forget the power of
humility
and learning and staying hungry foolish
and curious so the final part of the 20
20 20 formula is all about
learning and growing habit number six
exercise with kevin o'leary
i get up at five in the morning and i
ride the bike an elliptical bike
watching international business news
from five to six i also read some
reports during that period
i try and burn 500 calories then i do
some stretches for another 20 minutes
and so basically at about 6 30 i go
back upstairs and i put on my suit and i
go to work
i do that every day because that's a
routine that i like i learn a lot
because
the markets start over in europe and
they're actually in the middle of their
day when i'm working out on that bike
and i need to know what's going on over
there because it sets the trend
very often for the north american
markets because i'm an investor
usually what i like to do is walk a lot
in the morning
there's another way you can work out i
try and walk 10 000 steps a day
your phone or your watch will tell you
how many steps you've walked
but that should be part of your routine
exercise is very important long term
so if you're going to walk somewhere and
it's really easy to do walk to work walk
10 15 blocks it's fantastic it's very
healthy for you
and you'll feel better and habit number
seven the last one before a very special
bonus clip
is decide who you'll be with mel roberts
i was just about to ask chris a question
and i thought you should know that this
is a question that i think about every
morning when i wake up
here's the question what's your one goal
today
for yourself make it make it something
that matters to you
uh not a should not an obligation
something that that
matters to you that you want to do for
you
and then decide who you're going to be
today
wake up and ask those two questions and
it
it it's extraordinary how much it
impacts you having
a great day where you feel in control
my goal today
is to spend time with your hubby that's
so
cute that's not what i was gonna say
my goal today is to sit down
and set a timer for an hour and write
that's my main goal and
who i'm going to be today is i'm going
to practice being
present now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following through jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you i want you to control the first
part of your day
chart your start understand what it is
that makes you come alive
understand what is the action that helps
you feel bold creative
unstoppable we've all had it you've all
had moments where you
felt bold courageous and unstoppable
what led to that
reverse engineer yourself what led to
you feeling bold is it
watching a video is it reading a book is
it having a conversation is it doing a
meditation
is it taking your dog out for a walk is
it cutting the grass like i don't care
there's no judgment i don't care what
the thing is that makes you feel bold
and courageous and unstoppable
i just want you to do it daily i want
you to start your day with intention
most people don't start their day with
intention and that
makes the difference between the people
who achieve success and the ones who
don't and so chart your start
figure out the thing that makes you come
alive that makes you feel like
that big crazy idea of yours is actually
possible
and put that into the first 15 minutes
of every day if you did the thing that
made you feel bold courageous and
unstoppable
in the first 15 minutes of waking up
every single day
not every day will be amazing but i
guarantee you that your life will look
unrecognizable from where you are
right now chart your start
[Music]
if you want to know the five morning
routines of super successful people
check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i'm going to tell
you right now either you're going to
control your time
or your time is going to control you
that first
hour the victory hour is mission
critical
to you living